- Do you have what it takes
to succeed as a consultant?
In this video, I'm going
to give you an overview.
What, from my perspective,
the key skills are
that you will need to succeed in the role
in a large consulting firm
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, "Firm Learning".
My name is Heinrich. I'm a
former McKinsey consultant.
And on my channel, I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So without further ado,
let's jump into it.
I will now share with
you the top five skills
that, from my experience,
you need to succeed as a consultant.
And I will also share with you,
for each of these skills, one tip.
What you can do to become more successful,
more developed in this area.
The first skill I want to
talk about is business acumen.
And maybe you might already wonder
whether this is actually a skill
or whether this isn't something
that people naturally have, or don't have.
I strongly believe that
business acumen is a learned
and can be developed.
But first, let's better understand
what business acumen actually is.
And for this,
I will reference the
definition on Wikipedia.
"Business acumen, or also 'business savvy'
or 'business sense', is
keenness and quickness
in understanding and dealing
with a 'business situation'
in a manner that is likely
to lead to a good outcome."
So this is a bit of a soft term, indeed.
My perspective for this,
the implicit knowledge,
the implicit understanding
of business situations,
it is a bit of an intuition
that you will form over time.
What the right decision is for business,
or maybe also,
what just does not make
sense to follow at all.
And in my experience, an
absolutely necessary condition
to build business acumen
is an understanding
of fundamental technical
topics in business.
And this will be especially
things like accounting
and finance.
I would argue the most people
that have a solid understanding
on accounting and finance
will be able to build this
business acumen quite quickly.
But if people do not understand
these concepts at all,
they will really struggle to do so.
But why is business acumen
even needed in consulting?
But of course you will
facing senior leaders
of the client organization.
These people are experienced
business professionals
and, trust me, that most of these people
surely will have good business acumen.
And of course, if these people
pay significant per diem,
significant fees for consultants,
they assume that they can talk
to these people at eye level.
That these people have this
good business sense as well.
If you lack this,
you will completely
undermine your authority.
The client will not take you seriously.
And if you do that, you will
also fail as a consultant.
But now, how can you improve
your business acumen?
What can you do about it?
And of course, the best way to do that
is certainly a business education.
Nowadays, there are
lots of online courses.
For instance, there are
many MBA courses available
on online learning platforms like Udemy
where, for a couple of bucks,
you can get access to a
solid foundational course
covering these topics.
The next ability I want to talk to
is the ability to interact
and influence people.
Very frequently, especially in consulting,
you will be faced with a situation
where you want other
people to do something
even though you do not
have direct authority
over these people.
Indeed, often in consulting,
you work together in client teams
where you will be made
responsible for the results
that this team is producing.
But of course, as an external person,
an external service provider,
you cannot order these
people to do anything.
Indeed, you need to convince them.
You need to influence them.
You need to persuade them
that the things that you
believe are the right things,
that these are the things
that these people want to follow and heed.
This challenge is also called
leading without authority.
It is quite well studied.
There are lots of thoughts
and ideas around it,
how you can make this work.
The great thing about this
is that research on this topic agrees
that influence can be learned.
It is a skill that you
can develop over time.
To get you started on this
topic, in my video description
you'll find a list of
book recommendations.
And there are some books
that especially focus on this issue.
The first book I would
recommend you to get started
is "Influence " from Robert Cialdini.
Cialdini is probably the
most renowned researcher
on the topic of influence.
In his book, he explains
what the most important
tactics are to influence people
with lots of very practical
examples and insights.
The next skill that you need to have
to become successful as a consultant
is quantitative analytical skills.
Surely, especially in the first years
of your career as a consultant,
you will work with data a lot.
You will crunch numbers in
Excel and other programs
and a good, solid,
quantitative understanding
is definitely important.
The tool that you will use most frequently
to crunch the numbers is Excel, indeed.
And I definitely think it would
be very much worth your time
to improve your Excel
skills as much as possible
because strong Excel skills alone
can carry you in your
first years in consulting.
That can really make a
difference to your team
and therefore, also for your career.
If you do want to improve
your Excel skills,
I have a whole playlist
on my channel with videos,
showing you some skills
that are relevant for
working in consulting.
I will link this playlist
above here so check that out
to improve your Excel game.
The next important area of skills
that you need to build
are communication skills.
Of course, communication
is extremely important
as a consultant.
And it surely is also heavily interlinked
with what we talked about influence
a couple of minutes ago.
As a consultant,
you're frequently in a position
to lead client meetings,
to sit together also with senior people
in the client organization, talk to them,
convince them of your ideas.
And communication skills
are surely extremely important for that.
While in consulting, another area
where your communication skills
would be heavily assessed
is how good you are with PowerPoint.
How good you are with
creating slide presentation,
slide documents.
It is not only a cliche
that as a consultant you
will produce lots of slides.
For many types of projects, a slide deck
is one of the key deliverables
that you will leave the
client with after you leave.
So ensuring that this slide
deck communicates well
and delivers all the key
messages in a great way
is surely very important.
And if you would like to
improve your skills here,
I once created an end-to-end course
where I teach you all the skills
that you need to create
slide presentations
to the level of leading
consulting firms like BCG or Bain.
I will include a link to that course
below in the video description.
So if you're serious
about improving your slide writing skills,
I would recommend you to check that out.
Last but not least is resilience.
I do think that it is extremely important
that you develop some resilience
techniques for yourself
because otherwise the
stress and the pressure
that you will certainly face
on many of these consulting projects
will be very difficult for you to handle
if you do not have good
resilience techniques in place.
Resilience is a thing
that probably comes easier to
some people than to others.
But here, I also believe
that definitely there are
great ways to improve this
and to work with this.
In the end, resilience is a
lot about self reflection,
about personal development,
and setting the right
boundaries when necessary.
It is just the truth.
There are many consulting projects
you will be faced with
a significant workload
and then also additional pressure
imposed on you by clients
and sometimes, even also your team.
Being successful in
consulting is a marathon.
It is not a sprint.
So you need to make sure
that you do not burn out and have a plan.
Have techniques in place
that will carry you through
it in the long-term.
I once created a video where
I talked about techniques
that I use to cope with stress and anxiety
in my consulting job.
I will link it somewhere above here.
I hope that there are some
thoughts and reflections in it
that are helpful to you as well.
So let me summarize the five skills.
Business acumen, influence,
analytical abilities,
communication and resilience.
These are definitely important
for you to become
successful as a consultant.
And now I would love, of
course, to hear also from you.
What are the skills that
you felt were most crucial
while you worked as a consultant?
I will do my best to
answer every single comment
that you write.
I would love to get your
input on this as well.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel
to stay up-to-date on all my content.
I'm also active on other platforms,
such as Instagram, Twitch, and TikTok.
You'll find links to these platforms
below in the video description.
And indeed, I also have
an email newsletter.
I now want to say thank you
to all the members of "Firm Learning".
Thanks so much for your contribution.
You're really making a
difference to this channel.
If you are considering to
become a member as well,
hit the Join button next
to the Subscribe button
to learn more about this.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm the creator of "Firm Learning"
and I release weekly videos
every single Saturday.
So see you again next week.
Until then, good weekend to all of you.
Bye, bye.